ustedes seguramente están viendo en
pantalla o estuvieron viendo imágenes de
la zona del obelisco con muchísima gente
la gente que pasa detrás mío en esa
dirección estoy a unos 800 metros del
obelisco ahora y sigue llegando todavía
no tengo yo mis manos en mi poder cifras
oficiales pero algunos medios locales
están hablando de entre tres cuatro tal
vez más millones de personas que están
celebrando hoy en este festejo del
triunfo de la selección argentina en la
copa del mundo es posiblemente una de
las movilizaciones más grandes de la
historia Argentina seguramente la más
grande desde que yo tengo memoria y
justamente esta cantidad de gente en las
calles en las que está haciendo muy
difícil la circulación de ese bus y que
ese bus haga el recorrido que tenía
planeado en principio al obelisco ya han
dicho que no va a llegar había un plan
de que recorriera una autopista que pasa
por encima de esta avenida por la que yo
estoy 9 de julio Pero a varios metros a
varios kilómetros de aquí un par dos
tres cuatro kilómetros de aquí sin
embargo la gente subió a la autopista Y
está tan llena de gente que por ahora
tampoco es posible que pase por allí
vamos a ver si se descomprime y puede
pasar por ahí o hay un nuevo cambio de
recorrido es algo que a pesar de que la
fiesta continúa la celebración continúa
independientemente de eso ha generado un
poco de desconcierto en la gente que no
sabía para dónde ir y tenía mucha
expectativa de que la selección pasara
por acá